[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique une politique française en
plein flou sans boussole et c'est notre
thème du jour
est ce que la droite et la gauche c'est
fini le paysage est il en train de se
redessiner autrement pour en débattre
aujourd'hui sur notre plateau violaine
gillet bonjour bonjour vous êtes
conseillère départementale en saône et
loire et secrétaire du parti socialiste
de saône-et-loire ça françois deseille
bonjour bonjour vice président de dijon
métropole
je ne suis pas trompé cette fois et
président du modem de côte-d'or
damien quand un bonjour bonjour vous
êtes conseiller régional pour le
rassemblement national de marine le pen
et valérie loger conseillère
départementale de l'yonne les
républicains devaient être avec nous
elle a été victime d'un accident de la
route sans trop de gravité heureusement
lui souhaite un bon rétablissement
commençons par une devinette aller
facile mais qui vient de déclarer ceci
mardi regarder je ne veux plus m'en
faire mais dans le mot gauche des
millions de gens ne se positionne pas
d'un côté ou de l'autre il faut trouver
un vocabulaire nouveau ça n'est pas un
manuel macron ça n'est pas manuel valls
1 et parapher les gleek semaine c'est
alexis corbière le bras droit de jean
luc mélenchon on va assez loin sur
l'échiquier pour ne plus vouloir
utiliser le mot gauche
alors ça y est notre grille de lecture
notre façon de nous situer semble
obsolète
françois de seuils on s'est longtemps on
va dire moquer parfois du modem sur son
positionnement au centre est ce que vous
avez le sentiment de commencer à avoir
raison
je pense je pense que droite gauche
maintenant c'est devenu désuet ce sont
des termes purement français tirent dans
les pays on parle de travail et de
conservateurs de démocrates de libéro et
ça veut dire quoi être de gauche et de
droite parce que franchement qu'on
voyait la droite de juppé qui travaille
avec mouscron le modem la droite de
wauquiez qui flirte avec le fn par
l'assemblée nationale la gauche vous
avez les radicaux de gauche vous avez la
gauche d'olivier fort vous avez la
gauche de françois hollande avait la
gauche de l'amant de mélenchon ça
devient extrêmement complexe maintenant
c'est plus le logiciel ça complètement
changé
et à dijon moi j'ai essayé tenté en 2008
j'ai fait en tant que de droite modérée
travail etc la gauche on m'a dit mais
qu'est ce que tu fais les gens ne
comprenaient pas je pense que bayrou en
2007 avait posé les charges pour faire
exploser ce mur invisible entre la
gauche et la droite où on s'empêcher
travail étant de gauche modérée de
droite modérée travailler ensemble on le
faisait au niveau local n'est pas au
niveau national bayrou a failli le faire
il a simplement opposé les charges et en
2017 emmanuel macron un visuel
détonateur et tout fait exploser
on le voit le gouvernement il ya un
premier ministre de droite il ya des
ministres de gauche là va regarder le
dernier remaniement dimanche dernier
vous avez deux ministres issus du des
socialistes
et puis d'un ministre de droite modérée
des républicains mami li ça c'est
l'appareil mais on va falloir aussi
qu'on se pose la question parce que
pensent les citoyens quand on les
interroge les gens se disent maintenant
ça veut plus rien dire
faut prendre des bonnes choses des deux
côtés ce que je prône depuis des années
pour ça je pense j'ai peut-être est en
trop tôt maintenant je suis content
violaine gillet si on dit en gros la
gauche se préoccupait de des pauvres du
social et n'aimait pas trop les patrons
la droite se préoccupait de l'entreprise
défendez les plus riches ce qu'on peut
dire que la france a vécu dans ce
découpage longtemps et qu'aujourd'hui ça
colle plus où est ce que c'est un petit
peu et que c'est surtout réducteur je
crois que c'est une vision un petit peu
limité de ce qu'est la gauche est elle
se limite pas le clivage politique se
limite pas ce qui s'est passé depuis
l'arrivée de jupiter premier je pense
qu'on a quelque chose qui remonte à
beaucoup plus longtemps et là où on
confond peut-être quand on parle de
clivage gauche droite c'est quand on
confond les mesures qui sont prises le
plus ou moins d'état ce qu'on a souvent
pris pour la différence entre la gauche
et la droite
je crois que la différence entre la
gauche et à droite c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça ça remonte à beaucoup
plus loin
héron le fait remonter à la révolution
ceux qui sont placés à gauche pour
choisir maintenant c'est oublié ça la
mort l'endurance physique dans une
assemblée mais ça veut dire quelque
chose
choisir la mort du roi à ce moment là
c'est pas simplement être être pour
quelque chose qui est quand même
relativement violent c'est simplement
choisir la fin et l'abolition d'un droit
divin et c'est choisir que les hommes et
les femmes puissent prendre en main leur
destin et puis ce faire des choix de
société ensemble c'est le gouvernement
par le peuple pour le peuple qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui et pour moi c'est ça
profondément la gauche c'est ça et c est
ce qu en même temps ça tient encore une
référence de là aujourd'hui c'est
justement ça tient à ce que ça va tenir
ça va tenir il ya eu il ya eu des hauts
et des bas il ya effectivement un
mouvement de fond depuis on veut dire au
moins une vingtaine d'années où on voit
la baisse des partis traditionnels mais
la baisse des partis traditionnels ça
veut pas dire la fin de cette différence
entre la perception des choses
est ce qu'on doit laisser faire l'ordre
naturel est ce que l'ordre naturel c'est
de laisser gagner les plus forts ou est
ce qu'il y à un moment donné
l'intervention des femmes et des hommes
pour prendre en main leur destinée et se
faire un choix collective et la ja les
idées et il ya les partis et on va
essayer de comprendre peut-être la
différence entre les deux damien quentin
en même temps quand on adhère un parti
quand on est jeunes souvent il ya des
raisons pour lesquelles on adhère et
c'est aussi des positionnements on va
dire physique dans les partis politiques
par exemple beaucoup de gens au front
national puis rassemblement national
maintenant ont adhéré au parti parce que
par exemple qu'ils avaient une forte
opposition au communisme et donc ça si
tu es très à gauche sur l'échiquier donc
il ya des vrais il y avait ces valeurs
là et je suppose que vous voulez
partager aussi bien sûr on adhère
surtout sur des idées je pense monsieur
dassier l'a très bien dit macro à
participer à la recomposition de la vie
politique en france
mais je pense que le rassemblement
national il ya contribué fortement
depuis on va dire plus d'une dizaine
d'années nous avons toujours eu cette
même ligne du ni droite ni gauche et je
pense que c'est marine le pen qui a le
plus fortement contribué à cette fin de
ce métronome mortelle du droite gauche
droite gauche
la vie politique française était
colonisée par une bande de feignasses
qui attendaient que l'autre se planque
pour reprendre le pouvoir et et faire la
même chose
c'est l'hôpital qui se fout de la
charité ce qu'ils aient mois en matière
en matière de feignasses je pense que de
ce que j'ai vu en tous les cas dans les
dernières élections cantonales
j'ai quand même une adversaire qui n'est
jamais venu sur le terrain avec un
binôme masculin qu'on a jamais vu
prenez les bilans des exécutifs du
rassemblement national et vous verrez
que tout se passe très bien au parlement
vont monter
king on est on est nos élus sont les
mieux placés et donc aux mamans
participent présence et travail
nous avons en particulier participer à
cette recomposition de la vie politique
mais on a été aidé aussi par les partis
traditionnels notamment les républicains
qui avaient promis le kärcher à l'époque
mais qui n'ont jamais branché le tuyau
le parti socialiste qui a trait au
nombre de ses électeurs et maintenant on
met les formes d'assistance respiratoire
depuis la lenteur d'arsonval ou
débrancher uni droite ou gauche sans
pardon ni droite ni gauche mais avant
que marine le pen et on en parlera haye
sur le terrain social souvient noir le
pool pendant la campagne présidentielle
jean-marie le pen c'est la janais gêné
de d'admettre lui-même qui situait à la
droite de la droite avec un certain
nombre d'arguments qui était clairement
bien marqué politiquement et quand on
veut y aller vers ce parti comme vous
l'avez fait je pense en étant plus jeune
on connaissait ce corpus de penser là
donc droite gauche extrême droite
extrême gauche
c'est ça une existence a une
signification tout de même il y avait
peut-être une influence économique de
droite à l'époque du parti mouvement
quand georges a adhéré il ya aussi à
marine le pen qui a mené toute cette
fibre plus sociale et on nous c'est pour
ça qu'on a toujours été sur cette ligne
du ni droite ni gauche
on veut être on veut gouverner pour le
peuple donc soit des personnes de droite
ou de gauche
aujourd'hui nous ils rejoignent pourquoi
nous rejoignent pas parce qu'on est de
plus à droite ou plus à gauche parce
qu'ils ont été trahis par les partis
traditionnels
seul ps l'ump bon le modem c'est
différent ils vont un petit peu dans le
sens du vent il faut qu'ils sont voués à
un moment j'ai bien envie d'aller dans
le sens du vent mais je dire ça fait des
années que l'on prône le rassemblement
de ces mots on n'est pas ni gauche ni
droite
moi je suis avec la gauche avec la
droite si on veut encore payer ces
termes d huez top je considère qu'il ya
des gens bien des deux côtés
moi j'ai trop souffert savez la
politique pour moi c'est pas un métier
c'est un côté j'essaye de faire bouger
les lignes
quand j'ai entendu des gens me dire de
mon côté nos idées que la bonne bouffe
avant le modem vous venez de l'udf qui
était à l'époque quand vous étiez à
l'udf hamas n'a pas réussi at elle droit
me lé centre droit mais enfin marqué
dans la dans la fable à la droite et moi
j'ai toujours considéré y avait des gens
très bien au centre gauche qui à gauche
on pouvait travailler ensemble on l'a
fait à dijon il ya des gens très bien
des deux côtés
par contre c'est vrai que je considère
que ce n'est pas ni gauche ni droite
mais c'est avec la gauche avec la droite
c'est ça mon logiciel c'est pas du tout
ça c'est pas un logiciel ni gauche ni
droite
c'est sur ces ni fn ni l'extrême gauche
ça je suis d'accord et c'est pour ça
qu'on se retrouve les gens se l'espace
central il s'agrandit on le voit bien il
ya plus en plus de gens qui veulent
travailler ensemble dans l'intérêt
général parle du peuple mais moi je suis
aussi pour le peuple pour aider les gens
à y bien
je veux dire personnellement j'ai un ami
qui va être peut être recevoir une au
cutter je fais tout pour qu'il reste en
france c'est que plus de 6 en france
trouve ça lamentable de l'envoyer dehors
excusez moi et vous oubliez peut-être
mais moi je ne veux absolument pas et je
ferai tout je me battrai pour cela il ya
mais il ya un moment il faut travailler
pour les gens dire si on veut des
richesses ou bien si on veut le donner
des prestations sociales il faut des
richesses en amont c'est ça notre sens
est ce que ça va donner des idées de
droite et de gauche et travaillons
ensemble
non mais vous vous m'amenez sur la suite
si on essaie de trouver il faut aussi
trouver des concepts maintenant
puisqu'un certain nombre de rôles ces
ensembles de france 2 française se
retrouve pas dans cette idée de droite
et de gauche
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya d'un
côté du avec la droite avec la gauche et
d'un autre côté du ni droite ni gauche
jouer lens
et alors emmanuel macron essayé de
lancer cette différence entre
progressisme et populisme ce
progressisme qui réunit ray
les partis traditionnels de droite et de
gauche on va dire centre-droite centre
gauche
et puis le populisme d'un autre côté qui
appellerait le peuple contre les élites
violaine jds que c'est pas une chose est
ce qu'on se retrouvait là dedans ou pas
je vous ai passé j'essaie de trouver une
pièce du casio non mais enfin c'est un
peu facile
je voulais d'image le clivage gauche
droite il s'estompe
il se transforme il évolue il évolue
comme la société évolue aujourd'hui
essayer de réduire ça à progressisme
contre populisme c'est une facilité
c'est une astuce et c'est une stratégie
électorale faut être clair maintenant
dans ce qu'on voit ce qui se dessine
dans les prochaines échéances
on peut reconnaître qu'il ya un bloc
effectivement souverainiste conservateur
d'un vrai danger mais j'aimerais bien
entendre mon camarade qui est à ma
gauche d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur ce
sujet là on a on a donc ce bloc ce bloc
conservateur on a un bloc technocrates
libéral même s'ils mettent les techno
pour moi c'est les techno compris le
pouvoir et c'est pas la faute des techno
qui servent le pouvoir
donc voilà ce bloc technique techno
libéral et puis on a une position qui
est sociale écologique démocratique
solidaire qui est différente
effectivement donc la matrice et les
volumes elles évoluent je vais vous dire
comme le l'entreprise évolue aussi
aujourd'hui on parle d'entreprises
libéré on parle on n'est plus dans
pyramidale on n'est plus dans le
descendant et le citoyen comme le
salarié aujourd'hui il a besoin de
prendre la parole de prendre le pouvoir
et d'avoir confiance dans ce qui veut
dire que vous admettez votre parti parti
socialiste vous faites par contre ceux
qui sont dans la ligne actuelle de se
trouver des solutions et de faire
évoluer nous une manière s'est planté
avec les grands partis sont plantés que
la grande famille du ps qui a exercé le
pouvoir avec beaucoup de pouvoir
certains moments a pas renouvelé les
logiciels et faut trouver il ya eu des
erreurs dans le quinquennat précédent et
olivier faur l'a dit et a fait un
excellent bilan du quinquennat et je
dirais pas mieux que lui donc je renvoie
à ce bilan est par ailleurs
effectivement ce sont des partis qui
n'ont pas su évoluer et on est resté sur
quelque chose qui était de l'ordre du
quotidien mais comme dans beaucoup de
structures quand on n'innove pas ouvert
aujourd'hui depuis deux ans depuis c'est
à dire la leçon qu'on a reçues
démocratique au moment des
présidentielles
on a compris qu'il fallait refonder
il fallait alors on a un programme qui
s'appelle renaissance c'est drôle parce
que c'est le choix du nom qui a été fait
par la liste des manuels macron c'est le
deuxième petit coup de pied de l'âne
qu'on reçoit ce côté là alors ça en
devient ça en devient quasi comique
était le premier pas qui était le
premier l'opposition progressiste le
populisme damien quentin est ce que ce
que vous la trouvez pertinent tout
sachant effectivement que gauche et
droite c'était il ya une forme d'égalité
et que dans progressisme populisme il ya
un côté péjoratif sur les populistes par
rapport au problème nous rassemblement
national on parle plutôt de deux
mondialistes et de nationaux on le voit
d'ailleurs à travers trait à travers
l'europe ou en italie en autriche
d'élection en élection quasiment tout le
temps il ya une contestation très forte
qui monte contre cette union européenne
nous aujourd'hui entendu qui a pas du
tout de majorité pour les hauts niveaux
européens de façon globale pour cette
opposition
pour le moment oui pour le moment le
mais les sondages ne disent pas non plus
pour la prochaine élection va être clair
quand même oui mais il faudra être clair
aussi sur l'intention de notamment du du
modem du ps au parlement européen dans
quel dans quelle partie compte il siéger
vont-ils 2
encore une fois ça l'iédom c'est le
delliou peu de changements c'est votre
candidate n'a pas été capable de le dire
clairement à ces faits aux électeurs on
va dire quand même on va dire du nous
regarde qui ne le sait pas mais juge
vous coûte quelques secondes pour que la
compréhension
les français le savent très peu enfin au
parlement européen on va dire que les
républicains et le ps en gros était dans
la même majorité dans le mât mandature
précédente ce qui était quelque chose
d'assez ans c'était passionnant quand il
y avait un accord de gouvernement il
était dans un assez long terme et le
même groupe que vous mettez pas le même
groupe média d'un accord de gouvernement
quand on défend et quand on sait comment
ça fonctionne les textes sont amendés
groupe par groupe et vous avez le shadow
rapporteur qui va travailler pour son
nom mais on ne peut pas dire que c'est
la montre je voulais dire par là que de
toute façon car c'était différent la
politique 27 ans est à 80% il vote la
même chose le bois conseil régional la
croissance des choses bien tu les votes
c'est pas parce que c'est un composé qui
présente les choses qu'il faut voter
contre
oui bien sonné par exemple utilise ainsi
la jeune al quand je vois là quand je
veux
systématiquement les républicains
monsieur vos qui on l'entend le verbe
haut il l'immigration l'immigration etc
au conseil régional
le groupe républicain vote toutes les
aides à plus de 7 millions d'euros pour
les migrants que la gauche propose
désolé il ya un problème idéologique
c'est grâce à ça que le clivage gauche
droite est bien terminé et qu'on a les
mondialistes d'un côté et les nationaux
de l'autre et on va le voir à la
prochaine élection européenne ce que je
peux juste moi ça parce que franchement
comment est ce que vous envisagez les
choses alors on revient à la france
seule tous les pays de l'europe
reprennent leur souveraineté
concrètement c'est quoi parce que le
souverainisme très concrètement ça va
être quoi face face à l'amérique de
trump face à poutine
face à la chine la chine a déjà racheté
des dettes de l'italie et vous faites
quoi
on sera des nains on sera des nains on
sera tous exposés à des empires voilà ce
que vous proposez oulémas des milliers
de 95% des pays dans le monde qui ont
des frontières à 2000 avant le
remaniement
il n'y a pas tous les trucs sur mais là
j'ai bien compris ce qu'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a besoin de voir
qu'il ya des communautés d'idées qui
peuvent se faire au delà des partis par
exemple sur les dettes européennes
zampino sur les européennes on ne veut
pas recevoir de leçons d'une d'une
technocratie qu'il doit qui nous dit
comment on doit utiliser notre argent
pour faire quels projets nous imposer
donc la complètera l'ignorons
non non non non non alors je sais pas je
sais pas dans quelle mesure vous avez eu
l'occasion de collaborer un exécutif
quelle expérience vous à vis de ce sujet
là c'est pas c'est pas la technocratie
qui prend le pouvoir
c'est aux politiques de donner les
ordres quel que soit niveau et quand le
politique est faible effectivement c'est
la technocratie qui prend le pouvoir
et quand les technocrates prêt à
victoire va me reconnais aujourd'hui qui
ont pris le pouvoir donc c'est que vous
avez dans la mine globe ce n'est pas du
tout et le conseil européens pardon mais
c'est le conseil européen c'est des élus
le conseil européen c'est des élus bien
est-ce que les on a tendance à oublier
en france c'est quand même le conseil
européen qui décident de ce qu'on fait
en europe à un mot sur un autre nul ne
peut plus intervenir sur le thème
populariser excusez moi le terme pis
pour moi c'est complètement inappropriée
parce que aussi je suis populiste moi
aussi je veux que les gens les plus
démunis soit et des tirs je suis
quelqu'un de projets
pour tout le monde et pourquoi on
opposerait des populistes je pensais aux
progressistes pour moi il ya les
progressistes aprilia les démagogues ça
c'est pas pareil parce que populiste
quand on parle de police tout le monde
et pour les proches d'entre eux publient
sous ciel et l'idée d'opposer c'est
assez condescendant sa séquence d'élite
ouais m'enfin on utilise un peu mieux
condescendante moi aussi je veux que
tout le monde s'en sorte laisser
personne au bord du chemin
c'est vrai qu'ici personne entre nous et
j'espère le souhaitent dix ans après il
ya des démagogues d'extrême droite et
d'extrême gauche qui ont des discours
pratiquement difficile et je rejoins
madame sur l'europe veut dire que c'est
pourtant c'est pourtant un grand 60 mais
sans marine le pen elle va voir les
salariés de voir le poulet il se
préoccupe aussi de et pour de leurs
positions oui c'est très bien mais je
dirais comme marine le pen par de sortir
de l'europe et ses normes et de la
taverne il veut juillet la grèce
l'allier en écho christian ude a libre
nos idées son pouvoir presque partout en
europe un mot sur quelque chose qui
pourrait structurer aussi peut-être la
politique à venir
c'est l'environnement c'est le
réchauffement climatique est-ce que ça
peut être une piste de restructuration
l'écologie vraiment transpartisane
sécession se rend compte de plus en plus
on voit au sein du gouvernement on sait
un analyste européenne ase ans plus tard
on le voit au sein du gouvernement
nicolas blot la crainte et gouvernement
justement sur le sujet a donné 7 et 8
mai par exemple dans la liste europe le
numéro deux c'est quand même quelqu'un
des écologistes se dire l'écologie 'ça
de pareils que le populiste c'est ça
concerne tout le monde je veux dire on a
envie de laisser la terre la plus belle
à nos enfants etc
sauf qu'une fois qu'on a dit ça tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord actuellement je
partage je crois que ça va se faire et
qui se fait déjà jour c'est le clivage
entre ceux qui ont compris ceux qui sont
persuadés que l'effondrement est devant
nous alors je fais pas partie des des
échos l'aps
voilà je crois plutôt que l'évolution
sur le climat elle va être progressive
je sais pas si vous avez eu l'occasion
j'ai eu l'occasion d'écouter jean jouzel
ce qui va être terrible c'est que ce
réchauffement climatique qui seraient
irréversibles à partir de 2030
donc jean jouzel prix nobel et experts
du giec nous dit très clairement à
partir de 2030
on va arriver dans l'irréversibilité et
ça ne se fera pas de manière brutale
il n'y aura pas ce qu'ils auront leur
bunker et puis qui pourront qui pourront
s'abriter
ça va aller progressivement ça va aller
crescendo et ça touchera les plus
faibles et les plus démunis parce que
ceux qui ont les moyens ont déjà
anticipez ont déjà acheté leur maison
qui est à 1000 mètres d'altitude et ont
déjà anticipé les choses
donc ça va se faire progressivement et
le choix on a qui est devant nous pour
la quinzaine d'années à venir
c'est de changer ça et je parlais de de
gens qui sont capables de prendre leur
destin en main et de changer la société
mais c'est ça l'enjeu il est dans 15 ans
donc c'est aujourd'hui qu'on prend la
décision de changer et il ya un clivage
gauche droite
il ya deux ans je suis intervenu en
assemblée où un an et demi en assemblée
départementale pour prendre la parole là
dessus parce qu'on nous proposait un
rapport sur l'environnement qui était
réduit à peau de chagrin qui était
glissée dans le rapport d'activité
annuel et j'ai offert les objectifs du
développement durable à notre président
qui découvraient ce que c'était c'est ça
les objectifs du développement durable
n'en avais aucune idée ils découvraient
c'était ya à peine deux ans donc c'est
lui rendre c'est une vraie ligne de
fracture pas seulement entre la gauche
et la droite je crois que ça va toujours
plus large que ça et ça va être entre
ceux qui auront le courage de prendre
des mesures et pas simplement de
remplacer avec une taxe carbone les 5
milliards qu'on vient d'enlever sur l'
isf parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé
est ce que ça vous sépare climatique ou
pas non mais c'est pas une priorité de
marine le pen dans ses discours du tout
et on l'a même entendu jouer entre ça et
la vie quotidienne des gens demandent
des manifestations des idées jaune sur
les prix du carburant particulier on s'y
intéresse quand même aujourd'hui une
façon assez importante avec notamment
une personne question notre liste aux
européennes
monsieur religion à hervé juvin les
votes les votes de votre groupe au
parlement européen sur le sujet ont
rarement été dans le même sens que les
écologistes on est d'accord au parlement
européen possible mais je reviens
avec ma camarade socialiste au nouveau
conseil régional
l'écologie ce n'est pas nous mettre des
éoliennes partout partout dans la région
et c'est pas nous mettre du de la taxe
sur le carburant
quand je demande la baisse de la taille
si peur ou la refuse et l'exécutif
socialiste me dit ce sera que 50
centimes d'économies pour le compte pour
le citoyen d'économie au à la compagnie
sens du coup on voit donc vous n'êtes
pas d'accord sur l'environnement et sur
la primauté de l'environnement puisque
bien sûr dire je suis que je suis contre
le réchauffement climatique mais en
général ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas
pour toutes les mesures parce que je
rappelle que le rapport du giec le
dernier préconise que si on veut changer
des choses
alors il faut jouer sur les libertés
individuelles et sur nos modes de vie
exactement oui eh ben non on joue quand
on répond de cette façon sur les modes
de vie c'est du bon sens un produit
quand on achète un produit en circuit
court il doit être moins cher qu'un
produit importé d'un pays chinois c'est
du bon sens bon il faut mettre fin à
l'individu or hors sol et mais je pense
que pour l'écologie il va falloir qu'on
reprenne en main notre territoire notre
économie nos frontières ça va passer
aussi par je crois qu'on aura commencé
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur lopez
je crois que c'était de dire on s'y
intéresse quand même c'est quand même
assez révélateur ne s'y intéressent pas
juste quand même c'est la différence
entre un frère un parti qui travaillent
et d'autres même si on a été qualifié
effectivement au début de cette émission
par un terme que je ne reprendrai pas
vous reprendrez à l'assemblée nationale
et vous trouverez la lecture
intéressante
le groupe socialiste a pu travailler sur
le pacte pour la transition écologique
est proposé entre autres par nicolas
hulot la cfdt etc
sur les 66 propositions de ce pacte il y
en a 46 qui ont déjà été proposés sous
forme d'amendements à l'assemblée
nationale par notre groupe et qui ont
été systématiquement rejetées
donc il ya un double discours du
gouvernement actuel qui est pour la
transition écologique et qui par
ailleurs var détruire les accords au
niveau vous le disiez tout à fait
justement du conseil européen qui est
composée je le rappelle effectivement de
nos ministres et de nos représentants au
bout de tout ça il ya des élections
alors l'européenne vous avez déjà
commencé je vous remercie
on a même parlé effectivement c'est un
paradoxe puisque au niveau européen le
clivage gauche droite tel qu'on le
connaît fonctionne pas exactement
manière il va y avoir aussi dans la
foulée il y aura des élections
municipales derrière est-ce qu'on se
dirige vers une môme and tom électorale
différentes d'habitude est ce que ça
veut dire que tout le monde de votre
point de vue va se recentrer sur les
enjeux locaux et que les écuries
politiques vont un petit peu disparaître
françois de sales faut voir par exemple
déjà en 2014 je vous défie de voir les
logos politique s'il y en avait déjà
très peu le disait combien de jouer à
oullins c'est vrai je prends l'exemple
de dijon jeudi remis dans d'autres
villes mais je le vois bien que ça c'est
cette force à thiers fait disputer par
tous les candidats conviennent qu'ils
quittaient nous quand même cette
frontière invisible entre la gauche et
la droite est en train d accords ayant
explosé parce que avant 2008 j'étais un
ovni osé mais qu'est-ce qui fait lui il
va travailler que la gauche
maintenant on est sollicité et de plus
en plus ses portes s'ouvrent et on se
veut travailler ensemble cet espace
central s'est fortement élargis et on
travaille non pas dans un intérêt
national
c'est dans un intérêt local ça veut dire
quoi municipal c'est un intérêt c'est un
laboratoire des changements de reprendre
exactement de ce qui se passe au niveau
national c'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques années au niveau 10 ans avant
niveau municipal d'hier certains maires
n'avaient pas besoin des centristes pour
gagner il n'on pas le nom fait c'était
vraiment ils ont innové au sein dans
leur façon de faire de la politique
et là on le retrouve au niveau national
avec 10 ans 15 ans après et les
sollicitations ne pourvoit avoir de tous
bords politiques pour travailler
ensemble dans l'intérêt de la ville
c'est ça qui importe elle est aussi
cette façon de tromper les électeurs
monsieur des seuils et soutien de la
majorité présidentielle il a eu
l'investiture aux législatives est
aujourd'hui dans votre
conseiller municipal de dijon vous
siégez avec le parti socialiste et si
j'ai pas avec le groupe jonathan
marchessault opale rapport goethe
abandonné va falloir faire des choix et
ne pas vous avez vous avez pas compris
ce que je vous écoute et votre âge je
viens dire exactement que je travaille
dans un intérêt local
moi ce qui m'a intéressé mais quand même
on l investiture la république en marche
je donnerai vous demandez pas la laisser
agir les associations comme j'avais du
modem république en différence je suis
la même chose du prélat mélange de
mouvement démocrate sheila ce jeu je
suis pas président de la république a
man show côte d'or vous allez me faire
sa majorité lanthanides en ciel et oui
entièrement à 200%
mais je suis soutien je travaille j'ai
un bilan à défendre j'ai fait un
programme en 2008 en 2014 avec le maire
actuel de dijon et je défends ce
programme
j'ai désendetter la ville comme on a
nous avons travaillé 2 et l'endettement
de la ville plutôt j'ai pas désendetter
nous avons travaillé au désendettement
de la ville et c'est très bien
nous avons travaillé à l'investissement
nous avons maintenu l'investissement
désendetter la ville
c'est très bien mais moi je veux
travailler sur un programme je suis
quelqu'un de pragmatique je travaille
sur la ville moi ça m'a fait ça
m'empêche pas de travailler avec eux 1
comme adam le conseil départemental ya
aucun problème je suis fatigué je vais
bien je vais pas m'obliger à travailler
avec quelqu'un qui est mauvais parce
qu'il de l'autre côté de la maison vos
prochaines municipales six analystes la
république en marche et nice parti
socialiste vous allez sur la liste et on
verra on ne sommes pas là point c'est
mon premier roman je constate un clivage
entre les dogmatiques et puis ceux qui
font effectivement le choix de
travailler pour les populations
alors c'est bien de travailler avec tout
le monde je suis dans un groupe où on va
des communistes aux radicaux de gauche
on est en effectivement très ouvert je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne feront
pas un choix sur une couleur une
étiquette ou un parti ils feront le
choix sur la proposition qui leur sera
faite et les citoyens sont en train de
reprendre la main ils le reprennent sur
les réseaux sociaux ils reprennent sur
les ronds-points et la reprendront dans
les prochaines échéances ils sont
capables de lire des programmations des
élections crédibles que je pense à
tournus par exemple où il ya eu un
phénomène uniquement cours de mandat à
porter quelqu'un la société civile mais
à un moment donné ça n'empêchera pas la
réflexion de fond qui est de savoir quel
est l'objectif pourquoi est ce qu'on met
on met notre bulletin dans l'urne à la
fin est ce qu'on se soulage dans
l'isoloir ou est-ce qu'on fait un choix
pour une politique et pour un projet qui
est porté à un niveau municipal ou à un
niveau européen
voilà et qu'elle est on avait l'habitude
et la ténacité votre sanction ou des
votes confirmation peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à une certaine
maturité de la démocratie j'ai envie de
voir de manière positive
donc ça ce sera nos prochaines séances
les municipales c'est dans un peu plus
d'un an les européennes c'est bientôt
effectivement merci à tous les trois
alors ça pourrait durer beaucoup plus on
est au bout de ce débat avec au moins
autant de questions que de réponses que
de vous dire mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on aime la politique
merci à tous les trois d'être venus
débattre donc et puis avec une pensée
aussi pour valérie loger tous d'être
avec nous on pense à elle je sais
peut-être qu'elle nous regardaient en
lui souhaitant un bon rétablissement
restez avec nous pour la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis otelli reçoit gabriela talent le
secrétaire d'état à l'éducation et à la
jeunesse merci au revoir et bon dimanche
[Musique]